we have to leave you with some good  vibes courtesy of dwayne johnson the  rock paid a visit to madame tussauds in  las vegas and was uh took a moment to  admire khloe kardash's wax figure uh  placed right beside his own but and here  we go with this again but the rock had a  little request that is lower half a  little more like chloe's uh take a look  and we'll see you next time bye  i visited my madame tussauds wax figure  for the first time  i got to introduce you to my neighbor  i mean  guys  look at that that kind of looked cool  together right  and i only had one note  wait  guys can we  i mean that's amazing can we i need to  can we add a little bit more  to my like some glutes give me some  glutes like that